PERSON TO TALK ABOUT ALL THIS
WITH RIGHT NOW THAN
KAYLEIGH MCENANY, TRUMP 2020
SENIOR CAMPAIGN ADVISOR
KAYLEIGH THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
WE ARE CERTAINLY ALL IN THE HOME
STRETCH OF THIS ELECTION SEASON,
JUST THREE DAYS TO GO.
SO, WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD BE DOING
RIGHT NOW?
OBVIOUSLY HE’S HOLDING A LOT OF
RALLIES IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF HIS MESSAGE THAT YOU
THINK HE SHOULD BE GETTING OUT
THERE FRONT AND CENTER RIGHT NOW
>> WHAT HE’S DOING IS OFFERING
A CHOICE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE HAD A NOVEL VIRUS COME IN
FROM CHINA.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A
CHOICE.
OPEN THE COUNTRY SAFELY, WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OR  CLOSE DOWN
THE COUNTRY, JOE BIDEN WILL
CLOSE DOWN YOUR SCHOOLS, YOUR
CHURCHES, YOUR WORKPLACES.
YOU HAVE A CHOICE TO BRING BACK
THE HOTTEST ECONOMY IN MODERN
HISTORY WHICH PRESIDENT TRUMP
BROUGHT US HISTORICAL LOWS IN
UNEMPLOYMENT OR  GO TO JOE BIDEN
WHO BROUGHT US THE SLOWEST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SINCE WORLD
WAR II AND HE WILL RAISE YOUR
TAXES HE SAID SO AND FINALLY ON
HEALTH CARE COSTS ARE COMING
DOWN, PREMIUM COSTS, DRUG PRICES
ARE GOING DOWN YOU CAN CHOOSE
THAT OR  YOU CAN CHOOSE AN END
TO MEDICARE AS WE KNOW IT WITH
MEDICARE FOR ALL WHICH IS
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE AND SKY HIGH
PREMIUMS WHICH IS WHAT WE SAW
UNDER OBAMACARE THAT IS THE
CHOICE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE AND THEY WILL CHOOSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON NOVEMBER 3.
PETE: KAYLEIGH WHERE THE
PRESIDENT GOES WHERE
CANDIDATES GO TELL US A LOT
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON THE MAP
AND THE FACT THAT FRANKLY,
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
WAS IN MINNESOTA SHOWS THAT THAT
STATE THEY NORMALLY TAKE FOR
GRANTED IS ALSO IN-PLAY.
WE’VE GOT THE PRESIDENT GOING
TODAY FOUR STOPS IN PENNSYLVANIA
I BELIEVE, BUCKS COUNTY, REDDING
, BUTLER, WILL BE ENDING
OUTSIDE OF PITTSBURGH, THEN HE’S
IN MICHIGAN, IOWA, NORTH
CAROLINA AND DOWN IN FLORIDA AND
GEORGIA AS WELL.
WHAT SHOULD THE TRAVELS TELL THE
VOTERS AND PEOPLE WATCHING
THIS RACE ANXIOUSLY WHERE HE’S
GOING WHAT DOES IT TELL US ABOUT
THE CAMPAIGN HE’S RUNNING?
>> IT’S A GREAT QUESTION, PETE.
JOE BIDEN IS OFTEN CONFUSED BUT
RIGHT NOW HIS CAMPAIGN IS MORE
CONFUSED THAN EVER BEFORE.
WHEN YOU GO IN ONE BREATH TO
GEORGIA AND TEXAS AND THEN IN
THE NEXT BREATH YOU GO TO
MINNESOTA, A STATE NO REPUBLICAN
HAS WON SINCE 1972 A STATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALMOST WON BY
1.5 PERCENTAGE POINTS WHEN
YOU’RE STOPPING BY MINNESOTA,
THAT SHOULD WORRY YOU.
THAT SHOULD TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALL THEY NEED TO KNOW.
WE ARE LEADING I JUST CHECKED
OUT THE NUMBERS BEFORE I CAME ON
THE EARLY VOTE WE ARE 8 POINTS
AHEAD IN BALLOTS RETURNED IN
WISCONSIN.
TWO POINTS AHEAD IN BALLOTS
RETURNED IN MICHIGAN.
THEY ARE ON THE RUN TO FIND A
STATE.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD THIS.
HE HID IN HIS BASEMENT FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HE WON’T
FIGHT FOR HIS VOTES SO HE WON’T
FIGHT FOR YOU AS PRESIDENT SO
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND A PATH
TO VICTORY AND WE’RE CONFIDENT
WE ARE GOING TO WIN IN TWO SHORT
DAYS.
WILL: KAYLEIGH I KNOW THE
ELECTION IS THE FRONT OF
EVERYONE’S MIND BUT WE HAVE THIS
MASSIVE STORY THAT BROKE
THAT AN AMERICAN HOSTAGE WAS
RESCUED IN WEST AFRICA IN A
DARING RAID INVOLVING SEAL TEAM
SIX AND HERE IS A STATEMENT FROM
THE PENTAGON.
U.S. FORCES CONDUCTED A HOSTAGE
RESCUE OPERATION DURING THE
EARLY HOURS OF THE 31ST OF
OCTOBER IN NORTHERN NIGERIA TO
RECOVER AN AMERICAN CITIZEN HELD
HOSTAGE.
THIS AMERICAN CITIZEN IS SAFE
AND IS NOW IN CARE OF THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF STATE.
NO U.S. MILITARY PERSONNEL WERE
INJURED DURING THE OPERATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS IN
CONDUCTING THIS OPERATION.
THE UNITED STATES WILL CONTINUE
TO PROTECT OUR PEOPLE AND OUR
INTERESTS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
KAYLEIGH, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT WHAT WENT DOWN IN THIS
OPERATION?
>> IT WAS A SUCCESSFUL
OPERATION TO RESCUE AN AMERICAN
HOSTAGE.
WE ARE SO GLAD TO SEE IT UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT WE RESCUED 55
HOSTAGES IN 24 COUNTRIES AND IN
THE WAITING DAYS OF A PRESIDENCY
BEFORE A MASSIVE RE-ELECTION,
YOU TYPICALLY DON’T GET A LOT
DONE BUT THIS PRESIDENT IS THE
EXCEPTION.
HE RESCUED AN AMERICAN HOSTAGE.
HE SECURED A MIDDLE EAST PEACE
DEAL, HE PUT A JUSTICE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE VISITED OUR HEROS AT FORT
BRAGG THAT WAS SUCH A SPECIAL
MOMENT WHEN I SAW THE PRESIDENT
INTERACT WITH THE ARMY SPECIAL
OPERATIONS.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL HE SPENT AN
HOUR CASUALLY TALKING TO THEM
JOKING.
THEY HAD A GREAT TIME AND HE
PRESENTED THEM AN AWARD THAT’S
THE STORY OF THIS PRESIDENCY.
WE DON’T STOP.
WE GO TO 14 STATES, WE RESCUE
HOSTAGES, WE SECURE MIDDLE EAST
PEACE AND WE DO IT RECORD TIME
AND THREE DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
PETE: KAYLEIGH IT’S EASY FOR US
TO READ THE NEWS AND SAY SEAL
TEAM SIX CONDUCT SUCCESSFUL RAID
IN WEST AFRICA.
WHAT GOES INTO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
THE RISK?
THE POTENTIAL POLITICAL FALL
DOUBTS IF IT WENT THE WRONG
DIRECTION IT TAKES COURAGE TO
MAKE THE POLITICAL CALL AND TO
BE ON THE GROUND AS A NAVY SEAL
BUT THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
WE’VE SEEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
FROM THE PRESIDENT WHETHER
IT’S SOULEMANI, IN BAGHDAD THE
KILLING OF THE IRANIAN
LEADER WITH SO MUCH AMERICAN
BLOOD ON HIS HAND.
WHEN AND WHY DOES THE PRESIDENT
MAKE THESE CALLS WHICH ARE TOUGH
ONES TO MAKE?
>> THEY ARE VERY TOUGH ONES TO
MAKE BECAUSE YOU’RE RIGHT IT HAS
TO BE CONDUCTED JUST PERFECTLY
BUT THE PRESIDENT ALWAYS PUTS
THE AMERICAN INTEREST FIRST ON
IT AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
PLANNING, A LOT OF KEEPING
THINGS QUIET UNTIL THAT MOMENT
WHEN YOU GET THE GO-AHEAD AND I
WAS TALKING TO SOME OF OUR
SOLDIERS AND THEY SAID TO ME, WE
PRAY TO GET THE GREEN LIGHT
BECAUSE I SAID, YOU KNOW, ITS
GOT TO BE SCARY WHEN YOU GO INTO
THESE RAIDS AND THEY SAY WE WAIT
FOR THE GREEN LIGHT AND WE’RE SO
PROUD WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT
TRUSTS US AND GIVES US THE GREEN
LIGHT, TO TAKE OUT EL BAGDADHI,
THESE MURDERS WHO HAVE KILLED
FAR TOO MANY AMERICAN MEN AND
WOMEN IN BATTLE BUT THIS
PRESIDENT MAYS THE
COURAGEOUS AND BOLD DECISION
AND HIS RECORD STANDS SHOWS THAT
JEDEDIAH: WELL KAYLEIGH THANKS
FOR JOINING US GOING TO BE A FUN
, EXCITING NEXT THREE DAYS WE